Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Ermann ist mein Name.
Ich bin als Assistenarzt in Aufstattion Tätig.
Würde ich heute gerne mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Darf ich?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich würde zuerst einige allgemeine Fragen stellen und danach können wir über Ihre Bescheiden und relevante Vorgescheite sprechen.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Jennifer Scholland.
Jennifer ist eine Frau.
Ja.
Scholland ist der Nachname.
Okay.
Und Frau Scholland, können Sie Ihre Nachname und Vorname bestreiten bitte?
Jennifer schreibt sich J.
J?
J.
Ah, J.
Ja, vor Ihnen.
Oh, wen haben wir jetzt?
Also ich fange doch einmal an.
J-E-N-N-I-F-E-R Jennifer.
Okay.
Und die Nachname?
Nachname Scholland, S-C-H-O-L-A-N-D Scholland.
Danke schön Frau Scholland.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 12. März 1990.
1990, okay.
So, Sie sind 34 Jahre alt, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Und Frau Scholland, wie groß sind Sie?
Und wie schwer?
Ich bin 1,68 m groß.
Und wiege 60 kg?
60 kg.
60 kg, okay.
Und was sind Sie von der Ruf?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Lehrerin, habs du schön.
Okay.
Ist das ein Stressesjob, ja?
Ja.
Ein bisschen mehr, vielleicht.
Okay, jetzt können wir über Ihre Wischwerden sprechen.
Was für Wischwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe ungefähr seit 12 Stunden ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Sie sind in den letzten Stunden auch noch schlimmer geworden.
Das möchte ich nicht mehr.
Heute haben wir jetzt am Abend und jetzt kommt die Nacht.
Und das möchte ich untersuchen lassen,
woran das liegt, was das sein kann.
Okay.
Und seit 12 Stunden haben Sie ein Bauchschmerz.
Und wo genau haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ich kann Ihnen sagen.
Angefangen haben die Schmerzen so um den Bauchnabel herum.
Genau, okay.
Und jetzt sind Sie aber etwas gewandert in so mehr Rechts
in den unteren Bauch auf der rechten Seite.
Und ja, das tut ziemlich weh.
Okay.
Und jetzt haben Sie ein Bauchschmerz.
Ja, das ist ein Bauchschmerz.
Das tut ziemlich weh.
Okay.
Strahlen Ihre Schmerzen aus anderer Seite
oder nur in der rechten Region jetzt?
Nein, also der ganze Bauch tut jetzt weh,
aber hauptsächlich im rechten Bauch unten.
Da ist es am meisten.
Okay.
Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Nein.
Sie beschmerzen klopfend und so weiter?
Sie sind mehr drückend.
Drückender Schmerz und dauernd.
Er ist immer da.
Okay.
Aber die treten die Schmerzen plötlich auf, ja?
Oder erheh langsam?
Also die Schmerzen haben langsam angefangen.
Vor zwei Stunden.
Aber dann wurden Sie im Laufe der Zeit schnell stärker.
Okay.
Gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Und gibt es einen anderen Beschwerden,
die gleichzeitig mit Ihrer Bauchschmerzen starten?
Zum Beispiel Erbrechen oder Übelkeit?
Also Übel ist mir in, das war noch nicht so im Anfang,
aber im Laufe jetzt der letzten Stunden ist mir ein Übel geworden,
aber ich habe nicht Erbrochen bisher.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas,
das die Schmerzen verschlechtet oder verbessert?
Ach, wenn ich mich so ganz ruhig hinlege,
aufs Sofa, auf den Rücken lege
und die Knie etwas anziehe,
dann ist es vielleicht etwas besser,
aber nur etwas, ganz wenig.
Und das kenne ich nichts, was es für schlecht hat, für schlimmer.
Hab ich richtig verstanden,
rücken gegen macht Ihre Schmerzen verschlechtert, ja?
Nee, besser.
Okay.
Nur etwas, nicht viel.
Und haben Sie schon einen Medikament gegen diese Schmerzen eingenommen?
Nein, nein.
Mein Mann hat zu mir gesagt,
wenn du jetzt Schmerzmittel nimmst, dann ist das nicht gut für die Untersuchung
und dann habe ich keine Schmerzmittel und noch.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht ein Medikament eingenommen auch.
Ich würde gerne nach dieser Aufnahmegespräch
ein körperlösterer Untersuchung machen
und danach wir können einen Schmerz mit Zell geben, ja?
Okay.
Und haben Sie schon ein Atemnot
oder Bewisslosigkeit?
Nein, ja.
Also jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt nicht.
Ich habe das nicht bewusst los gewesen,
aber das ist jetzt schon einige Jahre her da.
Ach so.
Probleme.
Okay, okay.
Und ja, haben Sie eine Fieber oder Schüttelfrost im Letztes?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht,
aber ich habe vor zwei Stunden ungefähr gemessen,
Temperatur gemessen im Mond und habe ich 38,0 Grad.
38,0, ja?
Ja.
Okay, okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung.
Okay.
Und haben Sie eine brennende Giffel beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Alles ganz normal.
Okay.
Und Stuhlgang, wie ist Ihre Stuhlgang?
Ich glaube, ich habe vor 1,5 Tagen, 18 Stunden ungefähr,
aber da war nichts Auffälliges.
Ich habe keinen Durchfall.
Nichts besonderes.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut,
aber seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe
und ich die Übelkeit habe ich keinen guten Appetit.
Da möchte ich eigentlich nichts essen.
Ich möchte immer nur ein bisschen etwas trinken.
Okay, ja, das ist normal.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Letztes seit einem Gewichtverlust bemerkt?
Haben Sie abgenommen oder zugegenommen?
Nein.
Gewicht habe ich immer gehalten.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie normalerweise gut?
Ja, manchmal nicht so gut.
Der Beruf als Lehrerin ist manchmal ganz schön anstrengend.
Aber da sind so Phasen.
Meistens schlafe ich ganz gut.
Okay, okay.
Und Frau Schollanz, da kommen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Okay.
Trinken Sie der gelbeste Alkohol?
Regelmäßig nicht.
Mal am Wochenende trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein,
aber das ist auch nicht regelmäßig
oder mal auf einer Feier.
Aber regelmäßig trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
aber nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie eine Allergie gegen etwas?
Allergie weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe eine Fructose Unverträglichkeit.
Das ist mal vor einigen Jahren getestet worden,
weil ich immer Bauchschmerzen hatte und damals auch Durchfälle.
Und dann ist das untersucht worden.
Und seitdem ich das weiß,
halte ich mich etwas, was die Ernährung angeht,
daran, dass ich weniger fruchtzuckerhaltige Sachen esse.
Und da geht es mir besser mit.
Die Bauchschmerzen habe ich kaum mehr
und die Durchfälle sind auch weg.
Hab es eine Unverträglichkeit,
nur gegen Fructose oder auch die Lacrosse Milchsucker?
Ja, die Lacrosse Milchsucker.
Okay.
So würden Sie gegen Kindheitskrankheiten und Corona geimpft?
Ich glaube mal,
ein Impfpass ist komplett.
Die Hausärztin hat das überprüft und sagt,
ich brauche im Augenblick keine Impfung.
Ich habe vier Corona-Impfungen bekommen.
Ja.
Okay.
Und sind Sie kürzlich ins Ausland gereist?
Ja.
Ich war vor vier Monaten,
war ich in Griechenland.
Und vor zwei Monaten war ich in Südfrankreich.
Aber das war alles in Ordnung.
Da hatte ich keine Probleme,
kein Magen-Darm-Infekt oder so etwas.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Was ist das für Sie?
Was war das erste Land?
Ich habe nichts richtig verstanden.
Griechenland.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Ja, also einmal diese Fructose-Unforträglichkeit.
Und dann habe ich mit 23 Jahren einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen,
weil ich häufiger ohnmächtig wurde.
Und da hat man festgestellt,
dass ich ausgeprägte Herzrhythmusstörungen habe.
Und dass mein eigener Herzschrittmacher nicht richtig funktioniert.
Und dann bin ich häufiger umgefallen,
bin ich ohnmächtig geworden.
Daraufhin hat man mir einen Schrittmacher eingesetzt.
Und seitdem ist das alles in Ordnung.
Ich werde immer überbracht beim Kardiologen.
Das ist alles gut.
Okay.
Hab ich richtig verstanden.
Sie haben ein...
Ein Schrittmacher würde implantieren.
Wenn Sie 23 Jahre alt waren.
Da war ich 23 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Sehen Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja.
Als Kind wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Da war ich, glaube ich, 10 Jahre alt.
Und als ich 20 Jahre alt war,
da hatte ich einen Sturz beim Joggen.
Und da habe ich mir den linken Knöchel gebrochen.
Also unten am Sprunggelenk.
Da habe ich mir einen Bruch zugezogen.
Und der musste operiert werden.
Mit einer Platte und mit Schrauben.
Die sind aber dann nach 2 Jahren oder 1,5 Jahren wieder entfernt worden.
Okay.
Und wo genau hatten Sie ein Bruch?
Ein Fraktor?
Sprunggelenk.
Am linken Sprunggelenk.
Da am Knöchel.
Wir nennen das Knöchel.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben einen Schrittmacher.
Aber ansonsten nehmen Sie einen Medikament
gegen diese Herzritmusstürmung?
Nein.
Kein Medikament.
Nehmen Sie keinen Medikament da.
Okay.
Und ich würde gerne einige Fragen über Ihre Familie fragen.
Und sind Ihre Eltern anlieben?
Ja.
Der Vater ist 65 Jahre alt.
Er hat vor 2 Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Und vor knapp 10 Jahren hat er Postattack Rebs.
Er wurde operiert und bestrahlt.
Aber die Kontrollen sind alle gut jetzt.
Er ist dazu Frieden.
Mutter ist 62 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor 3 Jahren Eierstockkrebs.
Sie wurde auch operiert.
Er hat Chemotherapie bekommen.
Er geht es auch gut.
Sie ist immer relativ müde und schlapp.
Aber sie fühlt sich so weit ganz wohl.
Okay.
Und?
Ja.
Die Schwester ist 36 Jahre alt.
Sie hat eine Schilddrüsen-Unterfunktion.
Sie wird aber jetzt gut behandelt.
Sie ist damit wohl gut eingestellt.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja.
Ich würde gerne fragen, haben Sie noch regelmäßig Periode?
Ja, eigentlich ja.
Letzte Periode ist jetzt etwas länger her.
Die war vor 7 Wochen.
Für 7 Wochen?
Ja, sonst ist die immer ziemlich regelmäßig die Periode.
Okay.
Und?
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Frau?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Gynäkulatik.
Ich gehe regelmäßig zur Gynäkologin, zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Und da war bisher immer alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Okay, das war meine aller Frage.
Und Ihre Beschwerden sprechen über normalerweise
über Bindarm Entzündung.
Aber Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben eine Operation
gegen Bindarm Entzündung.
Ja.
Und ich würde gerne zuseist eine körpferliche Untersuchung machen
und danach wir können Bulut abnehmen,
vielleicht ein Bildungsverfahren durchführen
und danach wir können über Ihre Diagnose
und Beschwerde widersprechen.
Ja, okay.
Das können wir so machen.
Okay.
Ja, dann haben Sie etwas Zeit?
Ja, aber erst mal, Kollegen möchte ein Gefragen stellen.
Ja, ja.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen Fragen?
Hallo Frau Schönert, verhütten Sie?
Hallo.
Ich habe das letzte nicht verstanden.
Verhütten Sie?
Verhütten?
Ja.
Nein, wir verhütten nicht.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre letzte Bulutung
wo sieben Wochen ist, gibt es Möglichkeiten,
dass Sie schwanger sind?
Haben Sie einen Schwangertest gemacht?
Oh, das habe ich mir letzte Nacht,
als die Schmerzen anfingen, haben wir das auch überlegt,
ob es sein kann.
Ich habe keinen Test gemacht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Frau Scholland, haben Sie schon einmal
Fellgeburt oder extra utterengravity date
oder Abbruch?
Abbruch.
Das eine Wort kenne ich nicht.
Wie ist das extra?
Utterengravity date.
Anja, ich habe Schwangerschaft.
Okay, Anja, ich habe Schwangerschaft.
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe bisher keine Beschwerden oder keine Komplikation gehabt.
Das war bisher immer alles unabhängig.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay.
Ich denke, ich bin sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde sagen, 6.
Im Anfang war es weniger zu Beginn,
aber es hat sich dann jetzt relativ schnell gesteigert.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ich Haut gelblich geworden bin?
Haut?
Nein, ich bin nicht ausgefallen.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden.
Haut?
Nein, ich bin nicht ausgefallen.
Oder im Mund einige Bunde haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Beschwerden?
Schon einmal gehabt.
Ja, schon einmal.
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt, so etwas zu ähnlich beschwerden.
Das ist jetzt für mich ganz neu.
Ich habe vorgeschichtet, gibt es zum Beispiel oft Diarröte,
nicht fructose Intoleranz, andere,
oder Verstoffung, haben Sie bemerkt oder haben Sie?
Also ich hatte jahrelang, hatte ich Probleme mit Bauchbeschwerden
und auch mit Durchfall, aber dann wurde eben in dieser Test gemacht,
ich hatte die fructose, und das war sehr stark positiv.
Und seitdem ich das aber heiß habe, habe ich meine Ernährung verändert.
Und dadurch habe ich viel weniger Beschwerden, fast gar keine Beschwerden,
aber auch keine Durchfälle.
Danke schön.
Frau Scholland, spüren Sie einen schlechten Gewicht in der Toilette
oder haben Sie, wenn es Ausfluss gibt?
Ausfluss habe ich bisher nicht bemerkt, nein.
Schlecht den Geruch, haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Gut.
Sie haben gesagt, vor 18 Stunden nicht Toilette gegangen.
Gehen Wind ab.
Ja, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Der Schmerz ist auch so ein Dauerschmerz.
Er ist nicht wellenförmig, er kommt und geht nicht,
dann ist immer da der Schmerz.
Können wir als erstes beginnen?
Ja.
Gut.
Guten Tag, Herr Dr. Oberalachs.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patient genannten Frau Schinefer Scholland.
Und ich würde gerne über Sie berichten. Darf ich?
Ja.
Okay.
Frau Scholland ist 34 Jahre alt, am 12.3.1990 geboren.
160 cm groß und 60 kg schwer.
168.
Okay.
Und sie ist Lehrerin von Beruf.
Ja.
Und sie stellte sich wegen vor 12 Stunden bestehende Progrediente
und dauerhaftige im Rechtsseite Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Und sie berichtete, die Schmerzen im Verlauf geschlechter hatte.
Und sie hatte ein, die Schmerzen hatte ein Intensität von 6 auf 1 Decala von 1 bis 10.
Und die Schmerzen zuerst im pädiomalkaler Region angefangen
und danach im Verlauf, die Schmerzen auch die rechte Unterbauch,
die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen.
Ja.
Bezogen?
Okay.
Ich unterbreche einmal kurz.
Ich wiederhole mal das, was Sie mir gesagt haben.
Frau Scholland ist eine 34-Jährige Patientin.
1,68 m groß, 60 kg schwer.
12 Stunden über Abdominalschmerzen,
über Abdominalschmerzen, die umbilikal, periumbilikal begonnen haben
und im Laufe der Zeit in den rechten Unterbauch gezogen sind oder gewandert sind.
Der Schmerz wird auf der Scala von 1 bis 10 mit 6 angegeben.
Gut.
Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen sei drückend und dauernd.
Und die Schmerzen sei von Übelkeit begleitet.
Ja.
Übelkeit gibt es da einen Fachausdruck?
Nosea.
Okay.
Ja.
Und die Patientin berichtet ein Fieber von 38°C.
Wo hat sie das gemessen?
Unter der Höhle?
Ja.
Und Oral.
Sie hat das Oral gemessen.
Okay.
Und bis auf Appetitlosigkeit würden Vegetative Anamese unauffällig.
Und sie rauchen nicht und sie nehmen Alkohol nur am Wochenende ein Glas Wein.
Unregelmäßig Alkohol.
Ja.
Und sie nutze keine Drogen und keine Allergie sei ihr bekannt.
Aber als Vorerkrankungen sei Fructose in Toleranz ihr bekannt.
Ja.
Seit einigen Jahren ist eine Fructose Unverträglichkeit in Toleranz immer so ein Begriff.
Wir nennen das in Deutschland auch eine Fructose Intoleranz ist angeboren.
Und eine Fructose Unverträglichkeit ist erworben.
Ich glaube Kinder mit einer angeborenen Fructose Intoleranz haben,
das ist ein sehr schweres Krankheitsbild und ich glaube die Lebenserwartung ist nach wie vor nicht optimal.
Ich würde sagen Fructose Unverträglichkeit.
Unverträglichkeit.
Und die nur mit Nähungsverordnung behandelt.
Ja.
Oder die sie mit Diät erfolgreich behandelt.
Und wenn der Patientin 23 Jahre alt,
würde ein Schrittmacher bei Einheirsismus Störungen,
Adithmia, bei Adithmia implantieren.
Ich würde vielleicht Ihnen vorschlagen, sagen Sie,
im Alter von 23 Jahren erfolgte eine Schrittmacher Implantation wegen rezidivierender Syncopen.
Syncopen.
Ja.
Die Frau, sie hatte ja mehrfache Bewusstanzverluste, Ohnmachten,
wahrscheinlich aufgrund von bestimmten Rhythmus Störungen.
Und man kann sagen, ich würde es ganz einfach ausdrücken.
Im Alter von 23 Jahre.
Ist leichter als wenn Sie sagen, als die Patientin 23 Jahre alt war.
Lieber sagen im Alter von 23 Jahren erfolgte eine Schrittmacher Implantation wegen rezidivierender Syncopen.
Genaure Diagnose wissen wir noch nicht.
Das müssen wir erfahren über den Kardion-Logen oder über die Hausärztin.
Genau.
Gut.
Eine Appandectomie-Operationen sei ihr bekannt.
Im Kindheit.
Ja, sagen Sie anders.
Eine Appandectomie-Operationen ist eine Appandectomie im Kindesalter erwähnenswert.
Oder ja, ein Kindesalter erfolgte eine Appandectomie.
Und was erfolgte noch für eine Operation?
Ein Spungelenkfraktöre-Operation, ein Protise wegen Spungelenkfraktöre.
Also der Knöchel oder der Außenknöchel,
kennen Sie den Anatomischen Begriff des Außenknöchels oder Innenknöchel Maleolus.
Aufgrund einer linkseitigen Maleolus-Fraktur erfolgte eine Ostiosyntese.
Im Alter von 23.
20.
Was habe ich geschrieben?
Mit 20 Jahren war der Joggingunfall Maleolus-Fraktur linksseitig.
Wie auch immer das bezeichnet wird.
In Deutschland gibt es immer noch die Bezeichnung Weber, A, B und C.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht wichtig.
Die Maleolus-Fraktur ist besser als die Knöchelfraktur.
Ja, okay.
Und als Familienanamnese ist Vater 64 Jahre alt.
65 Jahre, ja.
65?
Okay.
Und vor drei Jahren hatte er ein Herzinfarkt.
Vor zwei Jahren, ja.
Und der Herzinfarkt heißt wie?
Myocardialinfarkt.
Myocard- oder Myocardinfarkt.
Ja, Myocardinfarkt.
Ja.
Der 65-jährige Vater hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Myocardinfarkt.
Das reicht.
Ja.
Und was hatte er noch?
Er hatte vor zehn Jahren ein Prostatakarsinon.
Ja.
Und ja.
Wie wurde das Prostatakarsinon behandelt?
Ich habe nicht gehört.
War es operativ?
Es wurde operativ und mit Radiazio behandelt.
Radiaziobestrahlung, ja.
Ja.
Und 62 Jahre über Mutter hatte vor drei Jahren ovarianikarsinon.
Ovarianikarsinon, ja.
Das zuerst mit Operation und danach mit Chemotherapie behandelt wurde.
Gut.
Okay.
Ja.
Und als Geschwister hat die Patientin ein Schwester 36 Jahre alt.
Und er leitet unter Hypothyroidie und gut behandelt
mit unter Medikamentösetherapie.
Ja, okay.
Ich würde vielleicht sagen die 36-jährige Schwester.
Bei der 36-jährigen Schwester besteht eine Hypothyriose.
Hypothyriose, die Medikamentös gut eingestellt ist.
Gut behandelt ist.
Ja, prima.
Danke.
Ja, was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose?
Normalerweise meine Verdachtstdiagnose war appendicitis.
Aber die Patientin hat schon appendicitis operiert worden.
Genau, zumindest sagt die Patientin das.
Sie berichtet das.
Ja.
Aber an anderer Seite, die Patientin berichtet,
die letzte Regeln, die letzte Periode war vor sieben Wochen.
Und vielleicht meine erste Verdacht auf ist Schwangerschaft.
Schwangerschaft, ja.
Aber als diffanzielle Diagnose kann ich appendicitis,
die war appendicitis und ovaritorsion.
Ja.
Und vielleicht ovaritarsin.
Ja, bei der Schwangerschaft, sie brauchen jetzt gar nicht so viele
Differenzialdiagnosen sagen, die haben schon richtig gesagt.
Ich habe es etwas leicht gemacht, weil ich gesagt habe,
sie ist schon an Blinddarm oder appendectomiert worden.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht gesagt hätte, kommt natürlich die
Appendicitis immer ins Spiel.
Aber sie haben das richtig gesagt, die letzte Periode war vor
circa sieben Wochen.
Und jetzt hat sie Schmerzen.
Und da muss man natürlich auch, der Begriff ist, glaube ich,
vorhin schon mal gefallen, eventuell eine extra Uterine Gravidität
oder wie auch immer denken.
Zumindest ist es wahrscheinlich keine ganz normale Schwangerschaft,
wenn es eine ist, zu starke Schmerzen.
Und da muss man auf alle Fälle gynäkologisch nachschauen,
was da vielleicht als Ursache hintersteckt.
Wahrscheinlich eine gynäkologische Diagnose.
Die Vertikulitis würde ich eher im linken Unterbauch vermuten.
Eine Sigma-Divertikulitis, aber es kann natürlich im Iliozyl-Kal-Bereich
durchaus Prozesse geben, die auch stattfinden ohne Blinddarm.
Und es ist immer noch, muss man sagen, jeder voroperierte Bauch,
auch wenn es schon Jahre zurückliegt,
kann auch Jahre später noch Komplikation machen.
Denkt, sie an Verwachsungen und was auch immer stattfinden kann.
Ilios, z.B.
Ja, genau.
Die Schmerzcharakteristik spricht so ein bisschen gegen eine
Obstipation oder Iliosyntomatik.
Der Schmerz ist nie wellenförmig gewesen.
Er ist immer dauerhaft.
Aber man muss gucken.
Differenzialdiagnostisch, denke ich, haben sie alles genannt.
Und ich finde, sie haben das auch sehr gut gemacht, die Anamnese.
Und sie haben das sehr systematisch gemacht.
Sie konnten sich gleich den Namen Scholand gut merken.
Der ist nicht so einfach.
Manchmal nehme ich extra etwas schwierigere Namen,
damit sie sich die Buch stabilieren lassen.
Das haben sie alles sehr gut gemacht.
Versuchen Sie weiterhin, das ist immer wieder meine,
das sage ich immer, versuchen Sie einfache Sätze zu bilden.
Nicht zu kompliziert.
Die einfachen Sätze werden am besten verstanden von allen
Menschen, von mir, von ihnen wahrscheinlich,
von den Kolleginnen, von den Patienten.
Lieber einfache Sätze machen.
Und dann kommt man auch nicht in Probleme mit der Grammatik
oder mit der Satzstellung.
Das ist, glaube ich, es lohnt sich.
Aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl für Ihre Prüfung,
dass Sie das gut machen.
Und machen Sie sich immer kleine Sternchen
an den Begriff Übelkeit, zum Beispiel,
dass Sie das gleich für sich übersetzen oder sagen
auch Schmerzen, dann eben Abdominarschmerz.
Dass Sie das gleich von vornherein in Ihrer Vorbereitungszeit
sich markieren.
Und dann kommen Sie auch auf die medizinischen Begriffe.
Das wird so sein.
Und der Knöchel, der Außenknöchel, der Maleolus,
das ist schon nicht so häufig,
nicht so häufig wie Appendicitis und wie
Stroma und Hypothyriose.
Das ist klar.
Gut.